you are watching cold-case Channel hey
guys welcome to another video this one's
kind of by a popular request a lot of
people have been sending me messages and
kind of asking me to put together
another wallpaper back and in HD this
time so you know I went along and did
that so this is kind of an art
technology so bringing art and
technology together in an interesting
way the selected wallpapers really just
pieces that caught my design I anyway
I'll show them to you now and I'll catch
up with you after this
so yeah that's most of them if you want
it come and get it the continuum
wallpaper pack along with previous
wallpaper packs will be inside the
description anyway hopefully there's a
few wallpapers in there that you like
and don't forget to rate comment and
subscribe I'll see you again soon for
the next video thank you